Speaker 1: I don't really know whether what
I'm going to show you next is hilariously
unhinged or sort of sad in a way, nearly six
months to the day after losing the November
twenty twenty election to Joe Biden and really
losing by quite a bit.
It wasn't close.
Donald Trump has appeared at his Mar a Lago
Club in Florida to sort of send himself and
his club members off for the summer.
Trump apparently is going to be relocating
to his New Jersey golf club for the summer
morogo.
Largo closes soon after Memorial Day, I guess,
because it just gets too hot and muggy in
Florida and Trump will head to Jersey.
And the goal, as far as we know, is to build
some kind of a political operation there.
And Donald Trump is supposed to just speak
to his club members and say thank you, have
a great summer.
He ends up ranting about the supposedly rigged
election claims.
They're looking at vote counts from all sorts
of states.
They're not nothing is happening anywhere.
Of course, Joe Biden has been president now
for months and even the crowd seems unable
to get into it.
You hear like an occasional cheer, but some
aspect of.
This is really sad, take a look at it and
then let's discuss
Speaker 2: let's see what they find.
I wouldn't be surprised if they found thousands
and thousands and thousands of votes.
So we're going to watch that very closely.
And after that, your.
When you watch Georgia, when you're going
to watch Michigan and Wisconsin and you're
watching New Hampshire, they found a lot of
votes up in New Hampshire because this was
a rigged election.
Everybody knows that.
And we're going to be we're going to be watching
it very closely.
But I don't think you just take a look.
It's on it's on closed circuit.
I guess it's all over the place because everyone
was talking about yesterday, front page of
The New York Times.
And they want to write it, but that's because
they thought they were going to have a negative
decision.
The judge gave them gave us a positive decision.
Speaker 1: So is this depressing or is it
funny?
This was once the president of the United
States.
He messed up everything.
He failed miserably on the pandemic.
It lost an election as well as losing the
House in twenty eighteen, losing the Senate
for his party in 2020, losing the White House
in 2020.
He's now living at a golf club.
I'm imagining him going to the buffet and
just ranting to anyone who will listen to
him about how it was all supposedly rigged.
Should we be mad?
Should we pity Trump?
What's the correct emotion here?
One of the things I am starting to think,
though, is that Donald Trump might genuinely
believe he won in November.
This is something we've been wondering for
a while.
Trump has, of course, been grifting around
the election for a long time.
I think Donald Trump realized early on in
the fiasco he wasn't going to be president
for four more years as like a practical reality.
But he realized he could keep scamming his
followers by raising money, by claiming I'm
going to fight with your money, even though
he knew he was never going to win.
But the question was, does he really believe
he won all along?
In watching Trump still rant about this six
months later, he seems to lie uncontrollably,
but to believe the lies himself.
And what I mean by that is when Trump says,
oh, they're finding votes in New Hampshire,
we're looking at that closely.
We're looking at this closely.
I'm leaning more and more towards Trump may
actually believe that.
So there's this debate.
Did Donald Trump know he lost or did he think
he won?
I think it's actually both.
I think Trump knew he lost in the practical
sense that he was not going to get four more
years.
But I believe Trump truly believes at this
point that it was stolen from him and that
he is the rightful winner, that Joe Biden
did not legitimately win.
So Trump both knew he wouldn't be president
and he was scamming his supporters in that
sense.
But by this time, by Friday at Mar a Lago,
he's no longer grifting.
He has convinced himself that he actually
did win.
He's now living in a world of fantasy, not
unlike what he's lived in for a long time,
even as a real estate business guy or as a
reality TV show host.
And I do.
I mean, I admit I get some pleasure out of
seeing that this is now Donald Trump's existence.
But with most of the 75 million people who
voted for him, still wanting him to be president,
if we don't take this seriously, he's now
going to Jersey to be close to New York and
mount a political operation.
He has every intention of playing kingmaker
in 2022.
If we don't deal with this in a serious way,
he could again be president, without a doubt.
And many of his acolyte suck ups could get
reelected in twenty.
Twenty too many new Trump suck ups, Trump
being elected officials could get elected
in twenty twenty two.
Now, one other thing.
A few people were posting this video to Twitter,
Twitter saying this must be four months ago.
Like Trump isn't still doing this in May or
it was the last day of April when this was
actually filmed.
I had the same reaction.
I thought this must be an old video, like
when Trump first went to Mar a Lago in January.
But no, this this is new video of Trump this
past Friday talking about how it was rigged.
And we're looking at vote totals very strongly.
Nothing's going on.
It's done.
And I believe at this point, Trump really
does believe it really does believe that he
won.
I don't think it's just a grift at this point
in time.
Let me know your thoughts about that at this
point.
Does Donald Trump really believe he won the
November twenty twenty election?
Let me know.
We'll follow up.